the last segment of today's show very
very heavy focus on religion two stories
about separation of church and state
today and then a voicemail that is also
religiously linked first story is from
the world of the justa or second story
will be about the world of the justice
system this first one is about education
in the state of West Virginia a bill has
been proposed by Senators which would
mandate that every public school at
least offer an elective class on the old
or New Testaments of the Bible or on
Hebrew Scriptures it was introduced not
surprisingly by two Democratic senators
just kidding obviously they were
Republican senators in Virginia I'm not
even going to tell you their names since
I don't care and they don't deserve
anybody know about them why do they want
these classes to be offered at every
school because the sponsors of the bill
feel that to understand contemporary
society and culture you have to know the
content of the Bible now any normal
person would say wait hold on a second
if the Constitution says there can be no
establishment of religion and then you
mandate that only one religion so-called
sacred text be taught isn't that a
violation of the Establishment Clause it
seems pretty open-and-shut but let's
think through what rebuttals could a
defender of this bill give one would be
hey listen it's not a mandatory class
it's an elective class but it doesn't
matter the fact that one religions or I
guess you could say you consider the Old
Testament a sacred text for both Judaism
and Christianity two religions have
their sacred text taught in class and no
others that is an establishment of one
or two religions over others the other
defense has been tossed around that if
you're a state's rightist we shouldn't
pay attention to what the Federal
Constitution says about this we should
look at what the West Virginia State
Constitution says and I did and it's
still not okay section 315 of the West
Virginia Constitution called religious
freedom guarantee it says in part all
men shall be free to profess and by
argument to maintain their opinions and
matters of religion and the
same shall in no wise effect diminish or
enlarge their civil capacities and the
legislature shall not prescribe any
religious tests whatever or confer any
peculiar privileges or advantages on any
sect or denomination
that's pretty damn clear right having
your sacred text taught in public
schools is a privilege that is being
conferred to only one sect or
denomination
lastly the sponsors of the bill and the
bill itself say that the class would
follow the law and all federal and state
guidelines to remain religiously neutral
but it doesn't say how and I would argue
that the mere existence of the class
means they are not remaining neutral
because they are saying of all the
different religions we could teach the
sacred texts of in the classroom we are
picking just the old or New Testament
which apply to one or at most two
religions yeah and you know they're
gonna cherry-pick the good parts and
leave out the Book of Leviticus Oh
horrible parts of the Bible I mean I
would be in support of like a world
religions class and that would be
constitutional of course but that's a
history class a history class where you
talk about Christianity and Judaism and
Islam and Hinduism and Buddhism and the
history of religion as a phenomena right
not necessarily the teachings of one
particular religion but this is what
we're dealing with in parts of the
country we have real decisions and
challenges before us pick your poison
right economic inequality climate change
the cost of college money in politics
net neutrality whatever and West
Virginia wants every school to be forced
into offering a Bible course god speed
that's the only thing I can I could
think of to say